Robert Pattinson is doing a little backtracking.
The star of the upcoming The Batman reversed
course on an assertion he's made a couple
of times in recent months: that Batman isn't
actually a superhero.
Pattinson first put forth his Bat-opinion
during a conversation with The New York Times
in October of last year.
While it's understandable that his opinion
would be a touch controversial among fans,
it's also kind of tough to argue with, and
it illustrates the interesting approach the
actor seems to be taking to portraying the
character.
He said:
"Batman's not a hero...he's a complicated
character.
I don't think I could ever play a real hero,
there's always got to be something a little
bit wrong...[Batman's] morality is a little
bit off.
He's not the golden boy, unlike almost every
other comic-book character.
There is a simplicity to his worldview, but
where it sits is strange, which allows you
to have more scope with the character."
Okay, that's all well and good, but Pattinson
really ran into trouble in December, during
a sit down with Today.
At that time, the star doubled down in a big
way:
"Batman is not a superhero.
It's weird.
I always balk at it.
It doesn't count.
You need to have, like, magical powers or
something."
All we can do is speculate as to whether Pattinson
has ever heard of the many, many superheroes
who don't technically have any powers.
Of course, when he finally did reverse track
on this controversial opinion, Pattinson did
so in typically cheeky fashion.
Speaking with TimeOut, the actor explained
that he thought he'd lost the role when the
fact that he was being eyed for it by Warner
Bros. was publicly leaked.
He was obviously excited when he was cast,
but ever since landing the coveted part, the
star has been the subject of plenty of fan
complaints.
Some of them, it seems, just don't think he's
cut out for the role, and those "not a superhero"
remarks didn't do anything to win them over.
Pattinson is quite aware of that fact, and
he explained to TimeOut that if he had simply
brushed up a bit more on his DC lore, he wouldn't
have said what he said.
That said, he didn't exactly back all the
way off of his comments.
According to him:
"I wasn't educated about the subject.
People got very angry about it.
It's bizarre.
I still can't understand the argument.
Okay, he's a superhero, I'm sorry!
The next headline: 'Pattinson retracts: Batman
is, in fact, a superhero.
He takes it back.'"
Despite the insane level of scrutiny that
comes with being cast as the Caped Crusader,
though, Pattinson is still beyond excited
for those fans to actually see the film.
He said:
"I'm only worried about [whether] people like
it when it's done.
Right now, people can think what they want...It's
the coolest thing ever.
I still can't really believe it."
We suppose his backtracking can't hurt his
standing with the fans, but many of them will
forever disparage Pattinson's casting purely
because of his involvement with the Twilight
saga.
"That's all superhero stuff, right?
What if I'm not the hero.
What if I'm the bad guy?"
We've pointed this out on several occasions
before, but since a lot of fans seem to keep
missing it, we're going to go ahead and do
it again: Pattinson is a far better actor
than his stint in the Twilight movies would
suggest.
For recent evidence, look no further than
his incredible performance in The Lighthouse.
If you're still not convinced, we submit 2017's
Good Time, a harrowing crime drama from the
Safdie brothers, who just turned in another
minor masterpiece with Uncut Gems.
Pattinson's desperate turn as a crook trying
to scrounge up the dough to spring his simple-minded
brother from jail must be seen to be believed.
Pattinson also delivered a stunning performance
in the 2018 sci-fi drama High Life, in which
he portrayed one of two survivors of a doomed
deep-space mission.
What we're saying here is that Pattinson has
spent his entire post-Twilight career absolutely
crushing it in extremely challenging roles.
That's why we're so certain that Pattinson
is a perfect choice to play Batman.
Of course, the proof will be in the finished
product.
The Batman is currently before the cameras,
and is slated to hit the big screen on June
25, 2021.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.